[Musik]
ich weiß sie ärgern sich über den neuen
termin
wenn es gut werden soll dann dauert es
eben manchmal ein bisschen länger aber
das warten lohnt sich ja dann auch sie
müssen mich auch verstehen
nein ok müssen sie nicht aber wird regen
sie sich nicht so auf wir kriegen das
schon hin
die neue deadline steht danke vielen
dank
ich habe wahnsinnig hallo peter kunz
alles harry potter ich freue mich sie zu
hören
sie haben den job seit zwei wochen
großartig ist wundert mich aber nicht
sie waren sehr gut vorbereitet natürlich
sehr gern jederzeit wieder ach ja als
auch das ja wird sich sich hier gerade
ihre tochter mit meinem bruder im park
soll ich die beiden turteltauben von ihm
grüßen
da werden sie bestimmt überrascht
ja natürlich kümmern uns in ordnung ist
später und alles gute
ist die höhe
eine sekunde
nein was ist